hello everybody hope they are good
Bitcoin is a 60k and it's only Wednesday
but look at this weekly candle it's huge
and it's pretty much what what the high
time frame chart was was saying and is
that if Bitcoin could manage to get
above 52,000 then you know there is only
thin air all the way to 60k because
there is no resistance in all this area
and we've got that in only one weekly
candle okay that's basically showing you
how strong the the high time frame is
and what
I like to chart it every now and again
and right now we're at the resistance I
60,000 but really we could even count it
all the way here is counting all those
weeks okay and that would take you to
let me Mark this for
you that would take you between 60,000
and 61,500 okay so that's going to be a
important resistance for Bitcoin this
area
here let me Mark it there di there is
going to be an important resistance but
then we're want to have the same case if
we can man manage to close above 61,500
then there is no there is nothing but in
air to 65,000 all right so kind of like
a similar situation to me the most
important thing of this High time frame
chart right now that we've done this uh
pum from here okay between these two
levels here is that we are R now
resistance okay and it's basically in
this area between 60,000 61,500 we're
right now at
6,400 so at anytime we could expect a
little retrace okay because nothing goes
up forever you can even see here during
this ball run okay yeah it goes up but
then there is a retrace there is a
retrace there is a retrace okay same as
here we go up but there a retrace is
appearing in the chart okay so perhaps
the new retrace is going to come around
this area that's what I'm expecting okay
a retrace between 60,000 and 61,500
because I think it would make sense it
would be quite healthy it would
liquidate a lot of late long positions
and I think uh it will be the most
effective move for the market to to make
next okay so I'm expecting a retrace
between 60,000 and 61,500 the truth is
yes I think that's the most likely thing
so I'm going to be looking for this move
but not especially to short it but to
long altcoins and I'm going to go
through it in this video perhaps today
it's a longer video but it's a beit
complicated okay so let me remove the
the high time frame chart remember the
resistance all the way to 61,500 so we
could see a retrace in this area now
what has happened in the last few hours
well the last thing that I mention on
Twitter is that last night we possibly
were experiencing a momentum cooling
down because you can see some weeks to
the upside the price couldn't break any
Fair the bll there was a week in the 15
minutes time frame and if you remember
yesterday's video I was telling you to
trade every week that is appearing to
the upside any liquidity pull but
especially weeks to the upside long
towards them because when momentum is
strong what is still going to go towards
them and I open a long position at the
50 EMA in the 15 minutes time frame I
was thinking if it was here or here but
it was lower because it was a 750 is so
it was in this Zone and I was targeting
this area of the week okay then at the
week take profits and an alarm to see
how price reacted because this got me in
the in the night time during the asent
session the alarm rank I woke up look at
the chart and all I see is basically on
let me remove this let me Mark the week
two I see this candle with full candle
body closing above the week and that is
telling me that price managed to break
Above This zone so nope momentum was not
coing down short trigger
validated price continues going up yes
there is a Weck here to the downside but
what's the matter all we care about are
weeks to the upside look at this week to
the upside failed okay only care about
imbalances to the upside when there is a
big up Trend like this all right go to
the 4 time frame we also saw here hang
on let me remove this we also saw here
this week here if you go to the one hour
time frame perhaps you see another week
no we're going to see a week in the 1
hour time frame but just navigate
between the 1 hour and the 4our time
frame okay that's where you're going to
be able to make the money this is what
we were saying yesterday only trade in
balances to the upside and keep an eye
for this area here to see if momentum
sft out but of course I posted on
Twitter very clearly we were looking
what happened with this candle after
week fill all right so short
invalidated and now price is continues
going higher 60,000 all right what can
we expect next well I'll tell you what I
think I don't really care about what's
going to happen to Bitcoin in this area
whether if we see a retrace or not in
this Zone I don't really care because
I'm carrying about alins go to the Daily
time frame of Bitcoin go to the Daily
time frame of any Alin let's go to arbit
room you can see the difference right
this is
ranging Bitcoin goes up change go to
chaining for example the same ranging
but is not going up like Bitcoin check
out again Bitcoin okay parabolic move
check again ER perhaps IA let's check
aox the same ranging but price is not
going up like Bitcoin Bitcoin is going
up like a rocket okay Solana the same
ranging but price is not going up and
the only reason is that if you check the
Bitcoin chart and then you check the
Bitcoin dominance chart is basically
going up as Bitcoin is going up okay go
to the 4our time frame look at the
Bitcoin dominance keeps going up and
that's what is a stopping altcoins from
moving now of course altcoins are going
to catch up with with Bitcoin at some
point and they're going to start to make
of those pumps okay that's what I'm
looking at uh some some people might be
telling you oh old season old season All
Season not really sure about it because
all I can see here is that we were
inside this range for look from May 2021
to May 23 that's two years of ranging
then we broke above the range tested at
support we call this move continuation
and now that we are seeing is sideways
move after an up Trend that could lead
to continuation all right I don't know
if that's going to happen or not but
there are no signs of an old season
so those people are calling an old
season here please say why why you
saying old season and you're not saying
why you think there is going to be an
old season because if you telling me
there is going to be old season is
you're expecting this why again uptrend
sideways move that can lead to
continuation all right and don't get me
wrong because the higher that we go the
drop the drop is going to be bigger and
this is going to be a much better syon
and this what we've been talking from
the start okay I'm very bullish in
altcoins I really like altcoins don't
get me wrong and I think that it's a
very good idea to have some altcoins now
the problem is when are we going to see
this old season then of course if we
start to see the Bitcoin dominance
dropping and getting back into the range
then yes you can expect Bitcoin
dominance to go to the back to the range
lows that's going to be an old season
but so far right now you cannot call for
an old season okay it's a more likely my
opinion that price continues maybe to 58
59% why not all right however this is
the weekly time frame I'm I'm All
interested in day trading or small swing
trading
okay trades that don't take that long
that gives you a lot of money basically
so what can we expect in the lower time
frame and when I say lower time frame I
mean for this week what can we expect
for this week well what I believe is
that Bitcoin if Bitcoin now drops okay I
have to explain this first when the
Bitcoin dominance is going up and
Bitcoin is going up altcoins are very
choppy that means that they are very
slow at moving up so they're going to
tend to be stable but if there is a
small dump here like a little retrace
altcoins are going to f that and they
are going to drop okay so alins are
going to behave like this while Bitcoin
and the and the Bitcoin dominance are
going to go up okay now because the
Bitcoin dominance and Bitcoin keep going
up this is to me the most important if
we see the r that I'm talking about in
Bitcoin that again it could go to 61,500
why not but altcoins are likely not to
move until a few days later when Bitcoin
consolidates the Bitcoin dominance
consolidates okay or even Bitcoin going
continue going up Bitcoin dominance
consolidate and that's when alins can go
up but it feels like this is still going
to be one or two more days for that to
happen Okay I don't know if that was
clear guys I hope yes but all I want to
say is that Bitcoin has done a parabolic
a parabolic move from
51,000 to 6
1,000 that's $10,000 move in only two
days and meanwhile altcoins have been a
stable not moving up just a stable okay
and what I believe is that Alin are
going to catch up with this move and
they are going to obviously go up once
Bitcoin starts to range or the Bitcoin
dominance does okay and for that might
take some time it still feels to me that
there might be one or two more days at
least before that really happens but Al
coins are going to go up
that's what I believe all right um in
the short term and with short term I
mean by the end of this week so in this
week I don't think that the next 3 4
days Alco should be starting to to catch
up with Bitcoin and pump quite hard all
right type of setups that I'm looking at
well also another thing if Bitcoin
retraces in this area between 60,000
61,500 so if we see a retrace of say $2
$3,000 move because the Bitcoin
dominance and Bitcoin is going up at the
same time altcoins cannot go up okay
altcoins what are doing instead is being
stable when Bitcoin and the Bitcoin
dominance goes up but if Bitcoin goes
down then Al are want to follow that
move they're going to suffer that pump
they're want to give us a very good
entry if that's the case and then when
Bitcoin starts to range again or the
Bitcoin dominance then alons can go high
so I would recommend you to also look at
cheap or cheeky buy entries also put
some some buy limit orders also lower in
case we get there with altcoins our key
levels like 4 hours 50 ma 1 hour 50 ma
um areas that usually there are take
profits of of of some sorts and that's
when you can exchange their position
okay from short to long so um that's
what I'm thinking we're want to go
through some examples you have arbitrium
arbitrium to me looks one of the best
examples right look at this you in
Bitcoin right Bitcoin chart is basically
something like this
and arbitrum is consolidating so of
course arbitrum I do believe the
arbitrum has the potential to go again
for example to 210 why not now 210 for
example from the 4our 50a that's a 10%
pump okay if it goes higher towards this
High which is very likely my opinion
that's a 15% pump all right those are
the type of Trades that I'm looking at
now to right now it's at a good price
but of course if we see the drop in
Bitcoin to the 50 ma that's going to be
a new entry for me 189 okay from there I
would be expecting by by the end of this
week at least a gain of
10% it's as simple as that okay what
we'll see what happens with our bitum
another alins but that's what I'm
expecting unless if Bitcoin drops and
retraces a lot like 5 6K which I don't
see that happening right now because
momentum is still very strong go go to
injective this has been the the best
performer Al of last year and a guy in
theam said this chart that it was uh
this kind of a structure and he said
keep an eye on guys for the potential H
support test and I did I Tred him
because I had a few confluences to
believe that like the 1 hour 50 Ma so I
put some bits at 3850 check what it went
to it went to 30
840 so uh that's already going up all
right Bo again I don't think this is a
bad price to enter But if Bitcoin
retraces a couple of thousand dollars
then in this token will go again to fill
this week h test again this potential
support the one or 50 Ma and that would
be a delicious entry all right for your
popcorns but anyway that's what you're
looking at okay you can enter now with a
small size and then if you see the drop
you can put big size because uh again
it's not Financial advice but that's
only the case that you agree with me the
Alin could be catching up with that
Bitcoin move right now if you are a
Bitcoin Maxi and you think alins are
going to go to the floor then close the
video okay because it's not for you but
I'm only looking at what can give you
money and right now what I can give you
money I think it's altcoins in the next
few days all right Bitcoin has gone a
massive move up I'm not buying a 60k
okay but I'm buying injective for 40 or
a 38 or 50 all right that's what I'm
looking at guys we can go through some
more examples chain link for example wow
well chain link has already done it it
is in the 15 minutes time frame yeah
literally go to the 5 minutes time frame
right now is doing it right now guys
okay this is what I mean this can happen
at any moment with any Alco that I've
been showing you AR vitum injective go
to Solana is Sol do the same no no not
yet but it can do it at any moment okay
that kind of
move so keep an eye on for alons because
they're going to catch up with Bitcoin
okay don't try not to short okay
because um you can look this in two
different ways you can see okay Bitcoin
is a very strong resistance maybe I can
short a
61k um is that really what you want or
you really prefer to long altcoins you
know uh it's two type of plays to me I
prefer to when there is momentum long
the lagging coins that are left behind
that they have to catch up okay so
that's how I plan to take advantage of
the next move guys so I hope that was
very clear and of course I'm going to be
charting more coins I'm going to post
them on the telegram Channel but I think
it's time to eat some pop coins so thank
you so much for watching guys and I'll
see you soon